what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm
starting a new series on the on the
channel called conversations with a
feminist with a potentially
former feminist maybe conversation's
underway i'm thinking about it after our
show right yeah yeah okay some critical
thinking going on because paul gave some
good arguments some good points some
very good points
so the reason um that i'm bringing you
here today okay is because you are
european yes where are you from so i'm
from the uk but i lived in germany for a
really long time so i'd say english
german that kind of thing yeah and so
here people look at me like i'm crazy
when i say i think everyone should be
able to own guns yeah me too like what
do you think we like that we everyone
should be able to no yeah that's i think
i think everyone oh you look at me crazy
i'm looking at you crazy yeah i'm i'm a
big i'm a big pro gun you should ever
you get a gun i'm like oprah you get a
gun you get a gun yeah and
so today i'm showing her put those on
shapiro
okay who is this guy ben shapiro is a
conservative media personality in the us
okay and this is the debate that like
put him on the map
so what happened was in the u.s there
was
basically a lot of like
mass shootings at this time i've heard
of those and i think this was around the
time of sandy hook guys correct me in
the comments if i'm wrong i'm pretty
sure it was around do you know what
sandy hook was like a probably big
school shootout or something it was like
a bunch of kids died from a school
shooting it was very sad it was really
sad okay and so but he believes in guns
and the other guy doesn't
okay so we're gonna there we go
is editor at large breitbart.com and the
author of bullies however less culture
fear and intimidation silences americans
so why am i off the rails mr shapiro uh
you know honestly pierce you've kind of
been a bully on this issue because what
you do and i've seen it repeatedly on
your show i watch your show and i've
seen it repeatedly what you tend to do
is you tend to demonize people who
differ from you politically by standing
on the graves of the children of sandy
hook saying they don't seem to care
enough about the dead kids if they cared
more about the dead kids they would
agree with you on policy i think we can
have a rational political conversation
about balancing rights and risks and
rewards of all of these different
policies but i don't think that what we
need to do is demonize people on the
other side as as being unfeeling about
the about what happened inside you
accused me of standing on the graves
of the children that died there how dare
you i've seen you do it repeatedly
pierce
like i say how dare you i mean you can
keep saying that but you've done it
repeatedly what you do and i've seen you
do it on the program is you keep saying
to folks that if they disagree with you
politically then somehow this is a
violation of of what happened in sandy
hook and you have yet i i i really like
to hear your policy prescriptions for
what we should do about guns because you
say that you respect the second
amendment and you know i brought this
here for you so you can read it it's the
constitution
and i i really like for you to explain
to me what you would do about guns that
would have prevented what happened in
sandy hook if you want to do what you
did in the uk right which is banned
virtually all guns that is at least a
fair argument and we can have a
discussion about whether that's
something that we ought to do i've made
it very clear what i want to do which is
exactly what mark kelly wants to do and
in fact rather than address let's talk
about that rather than address your
comments to me
about uh standing on the graves of
children at sandy hook you can address
them to mark kelly because he agrees
with everything that i've been saying
because he feels the same way as does
his wife they're gun owners they both
respect the second amendment of the
constitution they don't want to take
away anybody's right to defend
themselves with guns now they want to
take away certain types of guns they
want to take away assault weapons which
are capable with magazines that we saw
at aurora and sandy hook of unleashing
uh a ridiculous amount well this is a
question i wanted to ask you peers
because i've seen i've seen you talk
about assault weapons a lot and i've
seen mark kelly talk about assault
weapons the vast majority of murders in
this country that are committed with
guns are not committed with assault
weapons they're committed with handguns
so are you willing to ban handguns in
this country across that's not what i'm
asking for why not let me ask you don't
you care about the kids who are being
killed in chicago as much as the kids in
sandy hook yes i do then why don't you
care about about banning the handguns in
chicago no we'll come to that let me ask
you this
what do you think so far
his voice is really high pitched but
like
back to like what he's actually saying
like why is he so like pro guns like how
can you be so motivated and it's like
okay gun's so good like
oh okay no there's no reason why people
clap guns so i'll tell you why in the
u.s like this is why we believe in guns
so we believe it if there's a government
so let's say one time one day the wrong
person gets in charge right
we believe in guns are to protect
ourselves from the government so let's
say there's so that's why like
a lot of conservatives believe in
automatic weapons because we feel like
we have the right to defend ourselves
okay from either the government or if
you're in like a poorer neighborhood
like you should have the right to defend
yourself and your property
okay what a rich neighborhood too that
could happen anywhere but i just imagine
it's like less you know safe areas but
do you feel like
the whole idea of having done this just
makes the area less safe or the
likelihood that the government will do
what's the government going to do that
you're going to need a gun for
what if they i don't want to like
i don't want to like what do they do in
germany i don't know
but i think they do have guns in germany
yesterday no i don't not like i don't
think so i i could be wrong but i'm
saying like an example like like
sorry sorry you're from germany but like
with the like the jews right like yeah
like if they all were armed it would
have been much harder to do that
like yeah okay like because in that
place like the wrong person gone into
power right and you say okay if everyone
had a gun then that would have been okay
i don't think it would have been okay i
still think a lot of people would have
died but i think it would have been
harder for them to do what they did
if they had the choice to shoot somebody
that like tried to
get go on their property
okay
i don't know about that i feel like when
both sides has guns it just ends in like
bloodshed yeah but then here's the
problem let's say you ban guns that only
the bad guys have the guns because it's
the people that get it illegally
but don't people get their guns in
legally anyways in the us
the bad right the bad guys do right like
the people that like
have something to hide right they're the
ones that are going to get it so you're
saying like sketchy people will stay
sketchy and then people will still have
guns in america
yeah i'm saying if you ban
if you ban
getting guns legally yeah the only
people that will have guns are the
people that want to do it illegally
and those tend to be people that are
okay with breaking the law okay
i don't know i still feel like both
sides
with guns
in the day would lead to more violence
yeah than without the guns in the big
ship well do you think so do you think
the government can really get rid of
guns like even in the uk it's banned
here but i've heard it's like
not hard to get a gun if you want one i
feel like if you know how to use the
dark web you can probably get one
and like i don't know if you have in
like the us like um you don't have army
but like you know when people train like
they're in the army like military school
you know how to use a gun then we have
like the same kind of thing
and people use guns there
but they won't take them home like yeah
i don't know about that yeah okay i'm
gonna keep going because he's actually
gonna go over some of the arguments okay
okay let's listen to what banning
let me ask you this let me ask you this
wait really quick smash your pass
pass
what about the other guy pass double
pass
what was the weapon used in aurora in
the movie theater it was in yeah it was
it was an assault rifle sure okay what
was the weapon used in the oregon
shopping mall i believe he's an assault
rifle correct what was the weapon used
as sandy hook is an assault rifle what
was the weapon used at the incident
around christmas when the firemen were
lured to their deaths in new york state
finally and bought illegally that was it
that was that was an assault rifle so
the last four mass shootings in america
were all the assault rifles and the vast
majority of that is the reason mr
shapiro and you can smirk at me
like wiggles man you're smirking a
little bit i'm not gonna lie to you he's
doing a lot with his face right now
i think he knows that he's like winning
yeah he's like wait what's what
and you can accuse me of standing on the
grave
don't forget
people like me and mark kelly and
gabrielle giffords want to have assault
weapons like that removed from civilian
hands your passion on the issue doesn't
really justify the the rationale for why
you want to ban assault weapons
while we want to remove the preferred
weapon of choice
these killing machines well i would like
you in the hands of deranged young man
all i'm asking is for you to be
philosophically consistent if what
you're worried about is the removal of
killing machines from the hands of
deranged young people then maybe we
should talk about a blanket gun ban and
let's get to what the left really wants
here and the you know you say that
you're fortunate
left or right because in britain this
never is about left or right this issue
why is it here well you know we can talk
about britain in a second i think the
reason that it's about left and right
here is because fundamentally the right
believes that the basis for the second
amendment and they believe in the second
amendment the basis for the second
amendment is not really about
self-defense and it's not about hunting
it is about resistance to government
tyranny that's what the founders said
and that's what the right believes in
this country which tyranny are you
fearing yourself uh i fear the
possibility of a tyranny rising in this
country in the next 50 to 100 years let
me tell you something cares the fact
that my grandparents and great
grandparents in europe didn't fear that
is why they are now ashes in europe so
this this kind of leftist revisionist
history where there is never any fear of
democracy going usurpatious or
tyrannical is just that
just to clarify your position then the
answer to sandy hook as it was to aurora
as it was to gabrielle givers as it was
to columbine virginia tech is you do
nothing is that your position that's not
my position
my position is that we have to calibrate
laws that are designed to get hands-on
guns out of the hands of bad people and
keep guns in the hands of good people
who want to buy them idea
how do you do that well i think one of
the ways that you do that is by better
screening for mental illness i think
that you do better background checks was
adam lanza's mother a good person uh i
don't know whether she's a good person
or a bad person she's irresponsible with
her guns has it been any evidence to
suggest she was not a good person no but
there's been a significant criteria
wait a minute by your criteria of the
good people should be allowed the guns
and the bad people shouldn't she would
have been allowed the guns she was an
irresponsible person she didn't keep her
guns locked up and that and that should
be against you you have a mentally ill
person in your house so then i mean
we're talking about laws that we can
both agree with i don't know why you're
disagreeing with then she becomes a bad
person does she well no it's not a
matter of it's not a matter of morally
criteria good and bad so is she good or
bad you're right i should have said
responsible versus irresponsible that's
correct okay so she goes from good to
bad no she goes from responsibility
arguing about guns here
they're like arguing about
if someone's gonna vote bad person so i
feel like i feel like pierce morgan and
ben would like have like aligning morals
would it like if he took guns out of the
picture
i think
they could agree on something yeah well
i think ben's trying to find them at
common ground we're not saying like oh
we could agree that like mentally ill
people shouldn't have it yeah but he's
just like nah let's just talk about
i don't know something else like just
guns against guns yeah but still like
i don't get his his like ground over his
argument that like he's
i'm not grandparents or ancestors in
europe because he's jewish so he says
jewish so that's what he's saying
because he's from he's from like his his
grandparents were in i don't i don't
know i don't i don't know i'm assuming
like auschwitz or something okay so he's
saying like if my grandparents had guns
it might have been a different outcome
because the government
over like what it was a bad person that
got in control and then like they would
have been able to protect themselves but
there was no ban on guns
in that time i think anyone could access
a gun if they had one if they could
afford one are you sure yeah
so you've seen like okay this is like a
really bad source like in movies yeah
there's no like okay no it's just when
he's just curious i'm just gonna yeah
that's right
because i'm going from like peaky
blinders they had guns for guns but i
don't know if that was legal in germany
you might be right i don't know when did
that i don't know
were guns banned in germany
during
was that world war one or two that was
world war
two two okay
um
gun control in germany um
in in germany access
to guns is controlled by the german
weapons acts which
was first enacted in 1972 so that would
have been after i think you might be
right yeah
so like i think in that case i i think i
i want us oh history here we go
um
it's going to be oh no no the treaty of
versailles versilius included a firearm
reducing stag bends
um okay um article 177 further banned
all civilian use of firearms
in 1919. so that was before um
the holocaust yeah so i think i think
then it actually they would have been
banned it would have been banned but
even so i would say that even if they
did have guns
if the whole like government is against
them and you're like you have a gun i
don't think that's gonna save the world
i don't think it'll save the world but i
think it would have made it harder
yeah maybe like because at least i like
because i'm just thinking if i was like
in in their shoes right you probably run
off into the what like yeah it'd
probably make it easier to do like
because i think they started with
internment camps you remember like to
start like they first separated them and
like i think like you probably would
have had people shoot the guards and try
to escape
yeah i guess so like they probably would
have did more you know
maybe maybe and so that's that's because
a lot of times i don't think people in
europe like understand this concept that
it's not about everyone owning guns it's
it's about we want to be protected from
the government and that's why we think
we're entitled to have like a machine
gun because if the government comes
knocking on my door they're going to
have some big guns so i should be able
to defend okay hold that no imagine if
we did have guns in europe have you seen
like french people protest over
everything like anything
and you see they'll be in the streets
like
i know so like they'll be throwing like
multiple cocktails yeah about not losing
one holiday yeah imagine if the french
people had guns
if they'll be like no france they would
have all killed themselves so i do think
like it just leads to
it just escalates things no it does but
i think like then the guys that are good
with guns like there it's more they
protect people because like in some
states like guys okay like there's a
shooting that was stopped in a church
because the guy went to his truck
grabbed his gun and shot the dude
i don't know like i don't know how safe
i feel with like let's say there was
like a guy let's say i go to
you're from chicago right yeah yeah and
like your brother's packing and then he
does shoot someone but he saves the day
i'm like wait this guy just killed the
dude that's like really [ __ ] up well
if my brother shot someone that was
trying to shoot me i'd be i'd be cool
i could chill and get him no i get it
like okay we're safe but then they're
like
is your brother like a murderer now like
i don't know like he said the day but
like self do we have self defense like
laws like you you're you're not a
murderer if it's in self defense ah okay
so this is like a new concept for me
like
i don't really know i guess so but you
still get like yes you get like you'll
get years in jail for like why is
someone with a car on accident
let's say oh yeah but that's not self
defense like self defense is you pull
out it like you pull out a knife and i
shoot you
you try to stab me and i shoot you
that's self-defense i guess so but it's
like really hard to prove
yeah so if no one said i could let's say
it's like a group thing outside and
there's like okay this happened this
happened this happened like if it's just
you like you against me
and you say i say that you put a bull in
me and like what gun then then what
right well i i do think it's hard to
prove if there's no if we're just in the
house or something that that is harder
like you're right but like typically i'd
imagine one person doesn't live there
yeah it's kind of in the u.s like you
could shoot someone that's on your
property illegally
what so if i'm like oh and my ball got
to your backyard and someone didn't
notice i'm like damn i didn't know your
intruder i had to shoot this like 10
year old that jumped over defense to get
a football or something i'm going to be
honest i don't actually know the laws
around that i just know someone is like
breaking into your house in some states
you can shoot them what yeah hold on you
probably like i don't think a lot of
europeans understand like why we want
guns no i think that we think it's like
okay they just wanna they're like a gun
like yeah i just love the gun itself
yeah
that's what all the europeans and i tell
them i'm like guns bring them they're
like they always think i'm nuts and i
don't even i don't even want a gun to be
honest i don't own a gun
like i still think it's nuts i'm
thinking i never owned a gun
i can't imagine like rolling up to
america and like people just carrying
guns like someone gets at the car i'm
like oh like don't mind my god i'm like
on the side like yeah don't mind the
mess when i got rifles just on the couch
just just move it over yeah well you're
supposed to like be responsible with
them so most of the most people that
have guns take it very seriously like
you have to take i think you have to
take a course or something before you i
feel like you do but like i don't know
this is another unreliable source but i
watch dexter and those people get guns
and leave me anyways
like they'll just roll up to miami like
miami or in florida and like they don't
even have a gun license right yeah no
that's that's true and like you'll be
punished if you're caught with that but
like they can't catch everyone right so
that's why i think people should be
allowed to do it legally and the correct
way because at least you can screen it i
guess if people are gonna get them
regardless
i guess but i still think it's a bit
crazy okay let's let's continue let's
take a break let's come back and talk
more about this because
we don't agree
[Music]
hi my name's ben shapiro editor at large
breitbart.com and the author of
bullies do you believe that
if you had an assault weapon
ban statistics prove that you could dry
up the supply
of these guns and make them less
accessible to criminals um i don't know
whether you could make them less
accessible to criminals let's assume
that's the case that you could make them
less accessible to criminals again my
question remains for your peers and i'm
still waiting for an answer from the
left on this they say the pro second
amendment why don't you want to ban
handguns if you really want to solve the
quote-unquote gun violence problem in
america go after all the guns why just
stop yourself at assault rifles because
i believe and respect an american's
right under the second amendment of the
constitution that you kindly brought in
to defend themselves with a handgun or a
pistol what i don't understand most of
the murders are committed with those
weapons what i don't know well as we
just established as i talked to you
through them the last four mass
shootings in america adam lanza had two
pistols on him he was just having an
assault rifle he hadn't had the assault
rifle use them as you know and if he
hadn't had the assault rifle he wouldn't
have used them explain to me this i
can't buy this this is six packets of
suit effects one of the many companies
that make this particular
ingredient
which you can't buy legally in america
there we are six packets that is illegal
for me to buy in that quantity in
walmart say but i can buy an ar-15
military-style assault rifle i can then
as we saw with uh holmes the shooter in
aurora going at 6 000 rounds of
ammunition from the internet and i can
go and blow up a movie theater
do you think that's right well we can
talk drug laws another time but i think
the question is does that make sense to
you no i think that what i think what
would make sense is laws that are
calibrated to solve the problem so if
you think that the problem is only
assault rights which guns would you
remove i would i think the ones that
have largely been removed from the
market fully automatic weapons would be
would be a good start um i think that
you wouldn't remove any semi-automatics
at all and no because semi-automatic
just means that when you pull the
trigger once one bullet comes out you
understand how
bombers are essentially why he's like
which one i didn't know like he was
gonna be like who's gonna find organs i
don't get how you can be like halfway
yeah like he's not like oh yeah but hang
guns like they're fine but like yeah
like every movie i've seen with like
violence quite well uh-huh is with like
a handgun yeah
no like he's really like a normal person
can't really afford to get like how much
does an assault rifle even cost like
what like 2k
well at this time it was a big debate
because of the mass shootings that were
okay that was why
but
it's um so he's not like oh i hate guns
he's like just assault rifle well the
the reason the right gets kind of
like why don't you ban assault rifles
because we know that they really want to
be on all guns but they're just saying
assault rifles
yeah it's kind of like when republicans
say let's open a board let's like ban
abortions past a certain day
they really want to ban it completely
yeah and so he's just trying to show
like this is like you clearly want to
bail guns you just want to get your foot
in the door yeah
yeah but i kind of feel like he is like
yeah he's just like oh just assault
rifles which is surprising i thought
like like most british people like guns
no
right yeah this is kind of like this is
actually quite lenient no it's the
biggest thing when i come to britain
like whatever i send from chicago
they're like oh i know about chicago i
don't know like i'm not from that part
of chicago
but still like that's why like that's
why i find it scary like that's why like
one of the reasons i wouldn't go it's
like right but chicago has so many gun
laws
we have like we have a lot of gun
control like people it's very hard to
get a gun in chicago but i don't believe
that no it is i'm from there i'm telling
you in in states like texas it's much
easier to get a gun but like how hard is
it to get from one side to the other
with a gun anyways well texas to chicago
is pretty far but no you could just
drive over
exactly like i mean road trip
right pick up some ghosts but i think
the point the point is that the cities
with more gun control seem to have more
gun crime in the u.s so it's like it's
me
yeah it would seem like it's not working
because a lot of this like the most
crime dense cities
have like have guns banned okay
maybe they're just the most crime dead
cities the gun control's just not
working or maybe it's like the mentality
there maybe it's not to the guns itself
but still do you understand how an ar-15
performs when it's been modified and as
a magazine i do i started in the north
hollywood shootout you know what it was
illegal to do that and people did it
anyway we have we have 12 million
illegal immigrants in this country we're
not able to stop people people from
coming illegally into this country over
the southern border into places like
california where i live normally i i
think you'd be very hard-pressed to stop
guns from coming across that border
illegally as well i mean california has
some of the strictest
american to have an ar-15 i know not
every american who would you stop i
would stop anyone with a criminal
background i would stop anybody with a
history of mental illness and i would
stop and i would ask and not ask i would
require that people who have somebody
who has a criminal background or a
history of mental illness in the
household keep that gun locked up and
safe
what about the background checks forty
percent of all
uh gun sales in america now gun trades
are not covered by background i believe
in background checks for everybody for
everybody so there should be a database
a national register uh if it's not
public i don't like what happened with
the journal news putting out gun permits
which allows criminals to target
particular homes
well the nra came out today after the
meeting with the white house and just
said we're just not prepared to
entertain effectively any kind of
new gun restrictions
what do you think of that what's
astonishing to me is the left attack on
the nra because the nra is they don't
receive a dime of public dollars they're
not they're an interest group i don't
see you know it's funny the left they
like to talk also about violent video
games for example framing is left or
right because i don't have a horse in
the race i'm gonna vote either way
you you tend to be i hate when people
act like they're not on the left or the
right i don't know if this is big in
europe but yeah do you know i feel like
people like me more because i just said
i'm a conservative you can take care of
it
but i don't like it when people are like
oh i'm in the middle you're not in the
middle do you know what like off the bat
i don't like pierce morgan like he's
kind of conservative in my mind really
from what i've heard from what is said
really yeah oh my gosh we look at him so
left
no we like eat the rich like we don't
like him really yeah like i'm pretty
sure he's been banned off tv like he's
only this year he's like been allowed
back on tv he was banned i'm pretty sure
like he's like not been allowed like two
people don't want it on tv and now only
this year he's different like that's so
interesting because like we for you guys
this is like but then again this is what
he's famous for in the u.s like in
concert in the part of media i'm in like
pierce morgan but like the day he got
destroyed by ben shapiro was like he's
like okay this was you don't understand
him and conservative media this was like
it like did you see this did you see
this one
i'm so we're feeling no one is
destroying
me
like i'm sorry i'm sorry okay that's on
the debate that's also under debate but
like i like the way ben shapiro is
arguing like his case he's he's great
stay in this case i like it even though
he's annoying i find that annoying like
i don't like both of them can you tell
he used to be a lawyer
yeah i can see that that approach is
like first of all with the notes read
this
like do you have this that was the
funniest part i i came prepared
more to the left we all understand the
nra as you know are a very active and
well-funded and powerful body and what
they do why are you asking it
i just want to finish the point
this is very quick i promise the the
point that i'm making is this there's a
lot of been a lot of talk by a lot of
people about video game violence i
haven't seen david gregory interviewing
the head of the aclu and saying it's
your broad interpretation of the first
amendment that's responsible for this
but people are bringing on the nra and
saying it's your broad interpretation of
the second amendment that's responsible
for this they're an interest group if
you want legislation passed talk to
legislators don't go don't go to another
nra is i'm thinking about the thing in
ireland what are you thinking about
nra is the national rifle association ah
there's like some
i don't know if i can i don't know
there's like a group in ireland that
have guns as well okay it might be the
same thing i don't know thanks jones and
others do don't let me in with alex
jones fine after each of these massacres
they come out uh all the gun rights
supporters come up very strongly and
very vociferously
and they basically instill fear they say
if every
is still there if everyone in the movie
theater had been armed everyone at the
school had been armed it wouldn't have
happened and here's what happens
gun sales and ammunition sales rocket as
we've seen in the last three weeks oh
don't pass the buck pierce i mean the
truth is that the reasons
that the reason that people are buying a
lot of guns right now appears is because
people on the left are talking very much
about banning guns and so a lot of
people are saying if i can't if i'm not
going to have the right to buy purchase
a weapon of my choosing in two months
i'm gonna go and buy it now this is very
clear why does ronald reagan want these
assault weapons removed you know i don't
know why ronald reagan one of these are
you a bit of a you like reagan right i
like reagan in a lot of ways he's not a
god i don't agree with him on everything
did you agree with him also believed in
the progressive tax rate i don't believe
in that did you agree with him about
assault weapons um
if i believe what you're saying sure i i
don't believe i don't know
weapons i don't know what his position
on assault weapons was what are you
talking about let me read the letter
this was a letter that he penned along
with president's fallen carter in 1994
to congress while we recognize that
assault weapon legislation will not stop
all assault weapon crime statistics
prove
that we can dry out the supply of these
guns making them less accessible to
criminals we'd urge you to listen to the
american public and to the law
enforcement community in support of ban
on the further manufacture of these
weapons that was ronald reagan okay so
yeah i can disagree with ronald reagan
you keep friends
how is this election one of the great
right-wing presidents of modern times
agreed with me
so does it look all right is it no i
mean it is you deliberately
as a left-wing attack on the american
constitution and the second amendment
exactly what you've tried to do you come
in you brandish your little boogers if i
don't know my little book that's the
constitution
now he's getting mad about the noise
he doesn't want to read the note
he clearly he did not read it he takes
her founding
your constitution i've been debating
this for a very long time
i know the second amendment what i
haven't heard is one coherent reason why
any civilian in america needs an ar-15
military-style assault weapon tell me
why you need one i told you why why the
general population of america law
abiding citizens why do they need those
weapons they need them for the
prospective possibility of resistance to
tyranny which is not a concern today it
may not be a concern
to come from it could come from the
united states because governments have
gone tyrannical before this is not how
did you silence that here's where you go
into the absurd and the bullying you're
absurd you're stupid i understand that
i'm not the one that came in here and
accused you
of standing on the graves of dead
children because you're the one who's
doing that bullying punching back twice
you know what i call it step punching
back twice as hard in the in the words
of the president that's what i call
bullying and the most astonishing what's
astonishing what's astonishing about it
is that for weeks now you have been
saying that anybody who disagrees with
your position is absurd idiotic and
doesn't care about the dead kids in
sandy hook and then when i say that
that's a bully tactic you turn around
and say i'm bullying you for saying that
it's absurd it's ridiculous
let me ask you again
what do you
benjamin is good at arguing like you'll
circle back i'm like well actually
i wrote the book on bullying so
but i really don't get it like i really
don't get what's going on here okay okay
so let me let me explain so basically
what sandy hook happened yeah the guy on
the the on the left right pierce morgan
oh yeah you know who he is yeah yeah but
he was saying basically that people
that aren't for gun control like that
don't believe in gun control
like banning guns assault weapons don't
care about the kids in sandy hook and so
he's saying no that's a bullying tactic
because
you're you're attacking my character and
saying that i don't care but
we just disagree on politics okay so
it's like a logical fallacy that doesn't
mean that yeah and he's trying to use
that personal emotional connection
whatever that happened yeah to make him
like a bad person that's nothing to do
with gun laws yeah but like still like i
still don't get like what why is he like
so passionate about this argument pierce
morgan like how did he get like
british people don't really get that
involved i don't think was that involved
in like what's going on like i'm
surprised he knows what sandy hook is
that it was a really big deal like but i
don't like how old is this because i
like this
this is 2013. okay so why are they
quoting reagan
no no his point there was reagan as a
conservative president so he's saying
you're even you got like he the
conservatives
the same way that one girl in britain
conservatives love her
it's okay but basically like he's saying
i don't know
yeah but he's saying like you love that
guy
so like why don't you agree with him and
he's like well i can disagree with him
on that
yeah like yeah and also like this is
like how many years ago did you said
2013 yeah like my argument from like
1994. like yeah these were the rights
actually yeah like these are the
policies back then yeah
yeah
what is the point of a civilian having
an ar-15 assault weapon the point of a
civilian having an ar-15 assault weapon
many of them are ex-military right i
mean i have military friends and i have
no problem i don't have a problem with
colin powell owning an ar-15 assault
weapon it's not every civilian owning
them it depends on the civilian if it's
a criminal they shouldn't do it
what does an ar-15 look like it really
depends because like how big are these
guns because i really don't understand
like
sorry i should have showed you that at
the beginning this is an ar-15 it's a
big gun
see
that seems like a lot that seems like it
would be heavy that seems like you'd
have to do a lot of maintenance that
seems like a lot of work yeah for what
like
the off chance there's gonna the
government's gonna turn against you
could happen you don't know it could
happen like nothing happened
conservatives like i do get what people
are saying on the lines of like the
likelihood of that happening and the
investment you're putting in is really
high so you're investing a lot to have
these guns for the off chance that the
government might knock on your door and
try i don't know what
well okay devil's advocate though this
is this has happened so
it's not likely it'll happen now right
okay but pretty much every world
superpower has dealt with government
tyranny pretty much every society ever
that has existed like before us
has dealt with government entirely okay
guns in that mix would make things
better
yes i think i think people can protect
themselves more with guns i think humans
are stupid like inherently dumb you meet
more dumb people than you meet small
people i think if we all have access to
guns it's a bad idea i don't think
everyone's gonna like i have access to
guns but i don't get a gun like not
everyone's gonna get a gun yeah because
a lot of i'm not gonna i don't wanna
make this connection yeah but i've seen
a lot of dumb stuff done by people who
have access to guns well i'm gonna make
the connection that
i don't want more of those dumb kind of
people having more access to guns well
that sounds better i just i would say
that i think if they want it they'll get
it anyway so we might as well let the
people that really want to protect get
guns yeah but you can say that about
anything like if someone really wants to
kill someone they're going to kill
someone right somebody wants to smuggle
drugs they'll smoke a drug someone
really wants to do something they'll do
it right like right but that but the
that argument is like something that
directly like
like
like murdering someone i think is
different than owning a gun
because there's no way to murder someone
safely
or steal something like
you know what i'm saying but you can't
own a gun safely and like use it for
good you know like there have been
school shootings that have been like
lives that have been saved because the
right person had a gun to stop the bad
guy okay okay
um i get i get like i think there could
be stricter laws on like mental health
screenings i think mental health are
like how does a guy end up in school
with a gun for starters like that's what
i find the sketchy part like instead of
controlling all people using guns ban
them and just control people that enter
schools i know that sounds horrible for
kids
like you go to an equal you're not going
to see someone with like a bomb because
it's controlled
instead of like banning
everything
okay we're going to control this area
but i don't know but what if it's your
house
and like what about it like what if
someone breaks into my house okay and i
don't i don't want to die
and like like because you know like
murder happens so so
like what if the government comes
knocking on my door and they're like
like back
in
like if you were a jewish person in
germany like something similar to hat
that how would i protect myself if i
don't have a gun
okay
but this is like a highly
because it's like a hypothetical
scenario it's hard for me to sympathize
and like well like does it deserve like
if you had a gun then your life would be
safe and everything would be amazing
because even in the hypothetical
situation
your life isn't secure anyways right i
might risk that so it was like you
if i could shoot their head off yeah but
like it's not certain that you survived
that
does it like why would you risk the
lives of people that are like present
now in like the world as it is now like
schools and
people's lives and day-to-day life
that's like in the present
for like something that's hypothetical
that could possibly happen in the future
well it happens all the time like women
like like people like like i live alone
you know like
women men they get murdered all like
murders happen all the time okay i will
say that like i don't know how safe it
is in america i know state by state it's
pretty different yeah but i can imagine
some sketchy states i would appreciate
there's a dead body found like here
like down like literally
under the bridge right there you know
that's under the dialogue yeah like
literally nowhere yeah like it was like
a year ago but yeah
okay do you know that
anyway i should walk home this way
tonight well i don't think it's
i'm close but i feel generally safe here
to be honest but like st
do you feel safe because there's no guns
no i feel safe because my building is
like double locked
and i think it's kind of i think this
area used to be more sketchy than it is
i feel like now it's quite developed
it's like yeah
yeah but i think at one point it was
kind of sketchy but like the new
building's coming you know what i mean
it's not that there's no guns things in
london it gets gentrified like super
fast you could be like a sketchy area
like one year in the next year you got
to start books and whatever you and i
hope we get a starbucks i mean i think
it's on the way like
i would be real excited
um yeah
criminals are mentally ill but that's it
you can't
why do they need one to project against
the possibility of eventual government
tyranny this was the purpose of the
second amendment originally it remains
the purpose of the second amendment now
and pretending that governments have
never gone usurpatious before from a
democratic party
believe your own government is going to
turn on you in a way that you require
you may not remember ar-15 to challenge
them i mean you really believe it may
not turn on me it may not turn down my
children
it may not turn on me may not turn on my
children but the fact is this history is
replete with democracies going
tyrannical it has happened it happened
in france in the 19th century it
happened in spain in the last century it
happened in germany it happened in italy
it has happened repeatedly throughout
japan the reason we cannot remove ar-15
assault weapons is because the threat of
your own government turning on you in a
tyrannical way it is yes it is because
your position it is because there are
countervailing rights and
responsibilities
i don't understand why
why can't we bring
you have made your point crystal clear
people aren't stupid they can make up
their own minds ben shapiro
is that all he had to say at the end
yeah people aren't stupid yeah what that
was the end so okay okay oh wait let me
pause this so question
do you understand a little bit better
like why we want guns in america i kind
of get it now with the second amendment
so
if the government's like you know what
i'm gonna target this group of people
you want to be protected from that yes
but some people don't believe in the
second amendment yeah and the second
amendment can be like interpreted
different ways
so like
why should we be accommodating for the
only group of this group of people let's
say conservatives can interpret the
executive amendments that way i don't
think it can
because some people are like oh they
mean guns only in the case of something
extreme like you should have access up
that to them until like that point well
that's
so that determines so by state so
basically like the constitution means
federally like they cannot just ban all
guns but state by state have different
gun laws so if you go somewhere like
texas it's less strict and if you go
somewhere like chicago it's more strict
so it just depends on the state you're
in
okay
and it's up to you we have um a supreme
court that like their job is to
interpret the constitution so that do
you have a supreme court for every state
then
or is it fred really
i don't know how it works all i know is
like
yeah there's courts in every state and
if like one court can't answer it it
goes up and it will go up to the supreme
court right and so like when we were
talking saturday about roe versus wade i
like like that being overturned like
when that happened it was
basically like at one level they
couldn't answer it they send it to the
next level they get next and
what they do is they say this is what
the constitution says
so this is
so
like with rule versus wade what they
were saying was the old judges
misinterpreted the constitution but how
can they say that like how can you
reinterpret the law that's already been
interpreted by someone that was in the
supreme court it's very rare it's very
rare but yeah they said that like the
judges have actually the the document
that was leaked they were very harsh
they said like this was
like
i don't remember the words they used but
it was very much criticizing the judges
back to them
okay so yeah it can be like repealed if
they believed that the judges then were
wrong in their interpretation of the
constitution and what happens to those
people in america that believes that the
judges like in the supreme court are
wrong let's say like
they're like okay we think everyone
should have guns all state friendly like
california we're bringing guns back like
can like what happens to the people well
it's state by state so again like the
the evening supreme court says you know
what
everyone was wrong judges were wrong in
the past
which one so with the the abortion law
and the loves you
so they can't ban guns completely but
they can make it very hard to get them
in state in certain states so like
california it's very it's a lot harder
to get a gun than say texas okay and
like the the supreme court judges are
nominated by the president and they're
there until they pass away
so oh okay yeah i think or retire i
don't get like too sick or something but
like yeah so they're appointed
and by the president so there's like a
balance of this is why yeah like
conservatives are against the government
because like what do you mean that's the
setup of like
your country
some guys go all of making laws about
stuff interpreting the law well you have
to it's very hard to be like that is
that is like
you
even two
it's really hard to be a supreme court
just like you have to be religion yeah
it sounds kind of elite though like
to become that position is kind of like
okay some conservatives are actually
against the supreme court i feel like
i'll be kind of against the supreme
court a little bit i don't really like
that kind of yeah we're interpreting it
this way everyone just has to follow
with it because what if you're against
that then what
then pull your guns out because
um okay well i thought this was a really
good video i i enjoy like um you're a
really good sport with this stuff so i
like learning like what they're doing in
america like i was like what yeah now
but you can better like you understand a
little bit like i get it better like
okay second amendment that's what they
mean by that yeah okay yeah so it's
still scared of guns though yeah so fair
enough i'm not gonna change your mind in
one video but maybe maybe next time
okay guys um don't forget to subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
bell if you've watched two or more of my
videos and you don't subscribe we have
beef okay
yeah like like bro not cool um
love you guys i will talk to you guys
next time